هذا عبارة عن بولي إيثيلين منخفض الكثافة ، وهو عبارة عن
أكياس بلاستيكية خردة
يأتي بعضها من الولايات المتحدة
، ألقِ نظرة على هذه الحقيبة عليها
شعار Walmart وسأوضح
لك كيف يوجد مصنع هنا  في ماليزيا ،
تأخذ هذه الخردة وتدويرها ثم
تبيعها لإعادة استخدامها ، يتم وضع خردة البلاستيك من
خلال هذه الآلة
وتسمى الكسارة التي يتم تقطيعها
إلى شرائح صغيرة ثم يتم وضعها من
خلال تدفق التدفق الذي ينظفها من
الشوائب كل هذه الآلات  تنظيف
الشوائب المحتملة ، يتم إخراج اللب الورقي المعدني
من البلاستيك
ثم يتم ضخه بالأنابيب ثم تعال
وإلقاء نظرة على هذا يسمى
الإعصار ومن هنا يتم
تجريف البلاستيك هناك لمزيد من المعالجة
قد يبدو هذا وكأنه أنبوب ضخم من
معجون الأسنان ولكنه  في الواقع ، يتم
تسخين البلاستيك إلى درجة حرارة تزيد عن
216 درجة مئوية
، ويتم دفعه عبر مبشرة ويخرج هنا في
شكل حبيبات
، وهنا المنتج النهائي هذه
الكريات البلاستيكية الرائعة  التي يمكن استخدامها لصنع
المزيد من الأكياس البلاستيكية نعل حذاء التنس الخاص بك.
لذلك
يقول صاحب المصنع هنا ما قد
يبدو للكثيرين منا مثل القمامة بدلاً
من ذلك يبدو أنه نقود
كنت أشاهدها على قناة سي إن إن ماليزيا